皆様こんにちは。本日は n8n マスター講座にご参加いただきありがとうございます。どうぞよろしくお願い致します。
この講座はですね、皆さんにAIエージェント、つまりは自分で考えて動く賢い自動化の仕組みを自由に作れるようになることを目指しています。
また、それだけでなくですね、作ったものを実際のビジネスシーンで活用できるレベルまで、皆さんの知識、またスキルを引き上げることがこの講座の大きな目的となっています。
はい、これはですね、ただn8nの操作方法を学ぶだけではなく、最終的には皆さんがご自身で業務に使える自動化システムを作れるようになること、これを目的とした実践的なワークショップ形式の講座となっています。
本日ご参加いただいた皆様の中には、AI、そこまで使ったことがないよという方であったり、少し苦手意識、難しいんではないのかなと不安に思われている方もいらっしゃるかもしれません。
ただ、ご安心ください。これから私たちが使うn8nというサービスは、コーディング、また開発の経験がなくとも高度なAI自動化システムを構築できる、
今世界で最も注目されているノーコードプラットフォームの一つとなります。 この講座では n8n を実際に触りながら理解を深めていきますので、ご自身のペースでついてきて
いただければなというふうに思います。 ここでですね改めて n8n とはどういったサービスなのか
簡単にお話をさせていただければと思います。 先ほどもお話でありましたが n8n とはノーコードで様々なサービス
また、AIを連携させ、業務フローを自動化できるオープンソースのプラットフォームとなっています。
昨今、ChatGPTをはじめとした様々なAIツールがたくさん出てきたかと思うのですが、もちろんそのAIサービス単体でも非常に強力で非常に賢いものにはなるんですけども、
より便利にしてくれる AI 同士、また AI だけでなくツール同士、外部サービス同士の橋渡し役を担ってくれるのがこの n8n というツールになっています。
特徴としましては資料記載の通りですね、プログラミング知識は全く不要です。 直感的な操作で自動化ワークフローというのが構築することができます。
また、多数のサービス、現状ですと1000種類以上のサービスとの連携というのが可能になっているので、非常に拡張性も高いツールとなっています。
実際にこういった自動化ツール、業務の自動化というのを実現することによって、右側ですね、業務効率を大幅に向上することができたり、
あるいはですね、この n8n のツールに関しては何度もお話はさせていただいてますが、ITの知識、またプログラミング知識等が全く不要でこのツールというのを使って自動化システムというのが構築できるサービスになっていますので、非常に世界的にも注目を集めているようなサービスがこの n8n と言われる形となります。